um
[Music]
well it's been a very horrific time
recently
devastation
it's a sad time as well
so we pray
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom and judgment
as we face the tasks before us
you know and then and able us now and
always worthily
to discharge the sacred trust placed by
the people in our heads
i mean
apologies
um
counselor rabbit you worship
anymore
declarations of interest oh remember
apologies be received seconded
any discussion
question
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
declarations of interest
be no changes there
thank you public forum
no
thank you
you moved at the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the
infrastructural
services committee
held on the 22nd of march
2022
i will move i will move those minutes to
your worship
second deca worship
view discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carrie
that the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting of the performance policy
partnerships and partnerships committee
held on 22nd of march 2022
be received i'll move those your worship
god's second natural worship moved and
seconded in the discussion
question
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
he moved at the minutes of the meeting
of council out on the 22nd of march 2022
be confirmed
i'll say move your worship
second digital worship moved and
seconded new discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye aye
against carried
the minutes of the risk and insurance
committee
meeting out on the 24th of march 2022 be
received
how many of those you worship
i'll second that you wish moved in
seconded any questions discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against carried
that the minutes of the bluff community
board meeting held on the 28th
of
march
worship
second did you worship
thank you
it's moved and seconded
you need discussion i'll put it to the
vote
all in favor say aye
aye against kerry
the minutes of the extraordinary meeting
of the infrastructural services
committee
held on the 5th of april 2022 be
received
yes i'll move those and also the
resolutions adopted within
thank you
happy to see those who worship moved and
seconded
to discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carriage
i mean
our recommending we
do
have to take the one at the time
sorry it's what
stroke on here
okay
so we've moved out
on
by agenda
and we go now to
item eight
recommended that council
adopt
a revised roading and traffic by law
to incorporate the following changes
also
consulted
on alongside the speed
review um
just excuse me your worship with
in tab nine which was the minutes of the
extraordinary infrastructure
five april
uh regarding the speed deliberations um
when i moved the
um the minutes i also included
the adoption of the
resolutions that are in there
that's item 10
we've actually got four infrastructural
infrastructure meetings that occurred
that month
okay
so start with item 10 that minutes of
the
infrastructural services committee
meeting held
on the 5th of april 2022 be received
i'll move that to worship
i'd second that your wishes moved and
seconded any discussion
questions put it to the boat all in
favor say aye aye against
perry
who moved to 11.
that the minutes of the extraordinary
meeting of the infrastructural services
committee held on the 5th of april
2022 be received
you'll move that your worship
moved
moved and seconded
any questions discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
item 12 at the minutes of the
performance policy and partnerships
committee
held on the 12th of april 2022 be
received i'll move that your worship
second that your worship
thank you it's moved and seconded
your discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
order of the candidates names for the
local government trade
local government triennial elections
2022
now this is where we have to make a
decision
oh thank you michael good afternoon you
worship counter councillors
as i'm sure most of you are aware
october marks the upcoming trinial
elections uh this is the last
part for the council to determine before
we head into those and that is the order
of the candidates names you have three
options
option one as i'm sure you're very
familiar with is alphabetical so
surnames
listed and the voting papers in your
alphabetical order then there is the
nicely named pseudorandom
pseudorandom is where there is a random
draw of candidate surnames
and that order is how every voting paper
will show so
my voting paper will show the same
random order as yours
and then there is the true random
which every voting paper is different
and as we discovered
uh last year when a concerned voter rang
us
that included actually alphabetical is a
random
computation
it actually happened i
gave up trying to work out the maths on
the chances
so
the option is for you last time in 2019
this council moved to fully random for
the first time
as you'll see in my report there is an
increasing move by councils to
adopt a fully random
listing of candidates by surname
and with that i'm more than happy to
answer any questions
thank you questions
counselor love that
thanks michael is there a much of a cost
difference between pseudorandom and
random i'm just thinking of printing
setup yeah there's there's no cost
difference but our providers tell us
that the pseudo-random is actually more
confusing for their computers
uh than random i haven't got to the
bottom of why that is that that is their
indication to us i'm contemplating a
puzzled computer
open the pod bay doors hell
thanks
yes further questions counselors
yes counselor
it's not a question your worship i was
just going to say i'm prepared to move
the recommendations with
option c random order
or recommendation two
i would second that motion
it's moved and secreted
discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against carrick
amendment to the governance statement
council appointee to bluff community
board
alternative
he's taking us through that yep still
hear your worship
i've got the next two papers so this one
and the following one so
your worship this is a very uh simple
report uh given uh councillor kit is
unable to continue in his role as the
alternate councillor arnold
on the bluff community board uh the
a change needs to be affected for the
balance of the term uh and this will
amend the governance statement keeping
all things uh accurate
and councillor munzen has indicated she
is willing to
take on the role as the alternate to
councillor arnold for the bluff
community board so that is ever happy to
answer any questions
yes
i just like to
any questions or discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
city charitable trust appointment of an
additional trustee
yes your worship another one uh for me
my final paper for today
uh
this is again a consideration
just in light of the likely increased
workload for the charitable trust and
its asset
to help
the current trustees through that for
the balance of the
trainium
and on that i understand that councilor
sopa has indicated she is willing to be
appointed to this role and as if i'm
happy to answer questions and i note
your worship that
counselor clark has his hand up on zoom
oh
there you are thank you council
do you wish to speak to this
yeah thank you worship um
several things for the report for me um
um on
page
75 of board books
um i don't think it's appropriate to
suggest that councillor cyprus
appointment would give a gender balance
um this level of an organization and the
governance structure it's the best
person for the job so
while i'd be happy if the council was to
point councillors over
if that's the outcome we come to i think
the issue of being a gender balance
should not be a consideration
um i think that um
belittling to the skills that she brings
it makes the difference whether she's a
male or female my way thinking the other
issue from here as one of the three
trustees of currently on the
on the trust is i'm not sure where the
justification for the extra position is
i've spoken to chief executive today
about this
it creates two dynamics
one it puts four trustees in place
and so if there is any discussion about
what decision making goes on at that
level what happens when you have a 2-2
split
who has the casting vote well apparently
nobody does
and so uh
an even number is not an appropriate
level
um in my time on the trust
um
we've done very little in our three
monthly meetings
other than focus on rugby park
and so um
given that we probably at best got
two more meetings
possibly a third
before the change of council i'm not
sure why we would change our structure
and add another person and that's no
disrespectful isn't i appreciate you put
a hand up for it
but at the moment um
it seems to work okay
and as a report quite clearly states
that if um
if we appoint or don't appoint at the
beginning of the new trianium there will
be need to be reappointments i mean one
i'm leaving anyway but even if i wasn't
the trustees would still have to be
confirmed at that stage
so
to me that's the best time to be looking
at who you have on it what the future
work loads going to be and where the
focus will be and certainly
some understanding of the issues at
rugby park would be important
um
but i certainly don't agree with the uh
gender balance issue
thank you for that
thank you any
better discussion
questions comments
counselor partner thank you worship look
um the report states that um
there will be extra workloads so
um i will go by the report and obviously
um support that a fourth person is
needed and i think
more
more than area it provides a different
viewpoint than three
um
you've got the balance of someone's away
you can still meet and it's an effective
group
so i see a lot of
a lot of good reasoning why there is a
fourth
appointee
thank you worship um
did you move
no i haven't moved in um look i'm happy
to move the recommendations i know that
potentially there is concern
over
um
2-2 voting but i think in in this
instance if if we were in a position
where the trustees
were split then that's just a need for
more discussion
and more information until
you achieve um a decision by by
consensus
to safety though
thank you
counselor indicated she was interested
in speaking
well thank you um you'll wish it through
you your worship um excuse my little
sick child that's popping in and out
here
um
i really was just going to
ask if this was going to make it
significantly easier to achieve quorum
but i think councillor ludlow also
mentioned that fact
yeah
i'd be happy to support it
thank you
there's a discussion questions
are you seconding it alex
yes yeah i'd be happy just you can do it
on the proviso that it's quite clear
that it would be easier to achieve
quorum and it's the report states it's
needed
thank you can you clear the discussion
questions
put it to the verse all in favor say aye
aye
your worship i've got my hand up oh
so the way to avoid the um need for
further discussion and voting on a 2-2
and as some of my colleagues seem to
have new ideas come in why don't we add
two more things because the trustee does
allowed five
trustees currently got three
why couldn't we bring two more people in
that would cover the potential for me to
be leaving at the end of the term and
potentially for there to be a change of
the mealship as well
it's only a couple of meetings
well i prefer to keep to maintain the
status quo unless
but evidence that change is needed
so because there's emotion you worship
that would require an amendment
i'm happy to move an amendment that we
appoint two trustees
moved seconded
oh second amendment worship point of
order i think councillor scout would
have
a conflict of interest
as a venue manager sorry i will no
disrespect
and council ladler would be correct
well
i'll think of that they lady worship oh
helen did
so we've got a mover and seconder for
that amendment
any further discussion or questions
point of order your worship can you just
clarify whether or not the vote actually
took place
please
counselor um
clark did have his hand up indicated
you're not muted
so we've got a mover and second of the
amendment
hurry up
yes
hmm
oh
it suggested that
[Music]
we don't have
uh
to
have an amendment
because
trustee allows up to five
you have to put the original
motion to the back
all right
i wasn't looking at the screen at the
time i admit so
taking advice
your worship it might assist the
councils if they could hear the
officer's advice to you
see your worship
we are currently in a position where we
haven't had a vote on the original
so we still we still need to have a vote
taken in relation to the original in the
end in the amendment
point of order we would take a vote on
the amendment service before the
original yes
yes correct
correct so we need to
need to go through with the vote on the
amendment that's been placed forward and
then do uh vote on the original should
the amendment be lost
yes
okay
could you speak into the microphone a
bit louder i said as all the counselors
can hear
yes sorry your worship so
we need i'll just make sure the
microphone's working
we need to go through and do a vote in
relation to the
amendment
if the amendment is lost then we would
vote on the original
so we have not had a vote on the
original um just to clarify so it did
not get to vote stage so i would like to
clarify that
that is currently approved and seconded
okay
thanks your worship um may i ask a
question of clarification which mr
morris might be able to help
as i understand it and as councillor
clark pointed out the trust deed allows
for up to five trustees
anyway
so is the amendment even necessary could
we just appoint councillors open now and
we have
until the next meeting to see if there's
anybody else and interested and appoint
them as well
so through your worship the answer to
that is yes that is correct the trustee
allows up to five a point our five
trustees to be appointed
uh and that is an option available but
would require further amendments to the
recommendations should that be the
course of action desired by council
thank you thank you
your point of order in worship just for
point of clarification
the trust
that we're referring to has a meeting
this friday
i think it would be wise to have
if we're going down the path of having
two
people appointed to have both of them
appointed there i understand there will
be a presentation from staff at that
meeting about the earthquake prime
report that they now have from bmc
on the stadium
probably a very important issue and it
would be important that both trustees if
they were to be appointed are on top of
that issue
you wish a question if i may
um and it's not a procedural one but it
is more to the point of is there anybody
else who is interested in putting
themselves forward
because if we're going to sit here and
not find somebody that may be an
exercise in futility
does it have to be a counsellor
yes
okay under the current trustee to
worship yes
so is anybody interested in fulfilling
this position
all right well worship if i can
contribute i've got my hand up again
um
i didn't pick up why councillor skelt
had a conflict of interest
my
reasoning was that he's a manager of
another
venue in town so potentially in
competition they could
be competing for
similar events
just a point of clarification you
worship with counsellors get off
skilled on the
um
on the appointment
from council for the places and spaces
uh review that was done
no
it's awesome thank you
i'll maybe do help out the worship yes
that's required
so you're prepared to be a trustee
that's one position filled and one to go
we've already got one nominee sir
okay
put that to the vote your worship you'll
need a
change to the
um current amended motion
uh to appoint councillor arnold as well
you currently don't have a motion to do
that
i think uh councillor clark has his hand
up he may be willing to do that
more than happy to do that your worship
that the original
amendment i put was to a point five
uh sorry two more trustees up to the
total of five happy to name them as so
councillor sober and councillor arnold
thank you
let's sorts that out you now need a
second of your worship and then we're
almost there
i'll speak from there
clear the discussion
so
apologies your worship three minutes are
just catching up with uh the various
changes that have happened to the
motions
i'm not sure why we don't have the big
screen today clearly we've had a
technology fail
so what are you suggesting
if we could um mr day is ready
much
well i thought we're about to have the
shortest council meeting on record and
one that would never be beaten thanks to
covet
but um
i think we're getting
the issue in black and white now
almost
just
okay
is the big screen able to come down so
we can see the wording it's not there
today
i think that might help sorry council is
coming
let's go
you know
what's up
i think your worship the wording has
been put up for the councillors um just
noting that we've now got uh the
secondary and the uh person being
nominated as the same person so i would
need another second to his worship
worship second edit
thank you
thank you so it's ready to go to the
parish and we have just a discussion on
that
yes
yes certainly
cancel a pattern
um look i would speak against the motion
and the fact that um
the board of four trustees i think is
more flexible
it's more practical
the increase of
20
33
was stated for the very reasons i think
that
council is the ultimate
decision-making when it comes to any
financial
things to do with rugby park everything
has to come back through council
so i think five is one too many and i
will be voting for four
thank you anyone else wish to speak to
cancer clara his hand up your worship
all right
counselor
yeah thank you worship um
it's been my understanding that trust
has been in place since 2004
so that's 18 years
i understand that the only
delay or lack of a call
has been just the last one which wasn't
missed it was just delayed for about a
week and a half because i had an
operation so i don't think that that
justifies having a third trustee
um so
but i'll certainly go for the the wider
group because that was the thrust of
some of my colleagues that saw said
and i quote the more the
and
so
what's my view on that
thank you anyone else to speak to that
i'll put it to the vote then it's ready
to go
all in favor say aye
all right
against
that's a show of hands might be usually
worship all right
if you've got any view at all
please put your hand up all in favor say
aye
are you counting
four two three over here
anyone on the screen
indicated about
i'll be there of yep
six
three and five on zoom
it has no financial complications
ramifications so i will vote for
favorites absolutely no emotional
since there are no financial
ramifications and for expediency i will
vote and pay for the motion
thank you
contestarity
all right we have a clear majority
to clear the motion carried
is through any urgent business
perhaps before we move on to that you
worship with any of those who didn't
vote or would vote were going to vote
against it would like their votes
recorded for the minutes
i just just a point of clarification on
that you wish him to tidy it up
cancel the scout has abstained
apologies for that your worship i
thought it was appropriate to have the
minutes record that correctly
anyone who wished to
get the vote in opposition recorded
and that was you councillor pottinger
so that's that and adjusted
thank you your worship thank you
councillors
extremely urgent business
yes i had one you worshipped
just more more of a notification
just to let my colleagues know that
environment itself from tomorrow at 10
30 a.m
there is a presentation by the
helicopter rescue trust
that it would be helpful if somebody
from council went obviously claire and i
can't be there we'd be the normal people
to go
out of the mayoral forum recently there
was a um
some discussion around um
financially supporting this trust
invercargill elected not to
but gore and southland district did and
at that time the mayoral forum did
suggest to an environment southern that
they'd be best placed because they have
a ratepayer base much wider than
the individual councils
to um to pick up the hundred thousand
dollars that was being looked for which
equates to about 83 cents per year per
person or about two dollars per rate
payer per year
so that helicopter trust is doing a
presentation it's not open to zoom it
will be um it will be taped according to
uh the advice from our chief executive
and be available at a later stage but it
would be helpful to have somebody there
so somebody could go that has some
history with it darren or somebody else
if it's possible
i can't make it i could only zoom
sorry worship i'm already in a meeting
and i'm in the same meeting
from 9 to 12.
so who is likely to be available from
council what about you going your wishes
i don't feel like it but i don't care if
it means we have a quorum
well the present the presentation is not
to the three councils it's actually two
environments out there
so they can consider whether they pick
that up as part of their uh rate type
rate
um capture each year
they would
lobby their uh
ripos
so we don't need to
should we have
a representative
fundraising of the interesting
i think the meeting i have should be
finished about 10 so i should be able to
make it
if nobody else can
yeah thanks babe
well maybe it's hard making a decision
when you don't know what's likely to be
on the table
so
if if
an invitation can be sent to all
councillors
no you worship
there's no decision making on behalf of
the city
we've made our decision not to fund
the issue is should environment south
and on behalf of all ratepayers in south
and fund the helicopter trust and that
was the
collective view of the mayoral forum and
gore last time
so whoever goes it's just a little bit
more of
an information share about what goes on
and i guess to enter into some debate
from environment south and that the
mayoral forum would like them to pick up
that funding
i'm actually just looking there is an
email from liz that's just come through
shortly before we started this meeting
um
and it will actually be live streamed
so does that does that allow for a zoom
no it's a live stream so it just means
that you can watch what's going on
there's a link in the email from liz
the meeting is tomorrow at 10 30.
thanks matt okay well you've all got the
information
information
on your
whatever digit you're using
you have to put anything to the pad
okay
well thanks very much to the members of
the public a member of the public
and press
appreciate your
interest
and
i'll move that we go into public
excluded session our second education
moved and secreted in the discussion but
it's about it all in favor say aye
you